monsieur le ministre la parole et à
monsieur laurent furst merci monsieur le
premier ministre
le chômage vient d'augmenter pour la 32e
fois sur 36 mois de présidence
hollande plus 1,1 million de chômeurs
supplémentaires
est-ce que vous mesurer l'ampleur du
désastre social
est-ce que vous mesurez la dimension de
votre échec
est-ce que vous mesurez la déception
dans laquelle vous avez plongé tout le
pays
est-ce que vous mesurez qu'au bout de la
chaîne ce sont des femmes des hommes de
tous âges d'origine différente de
régions différentes qui souffrent et qui
ne savent plus vers quel ciel se tourner
vous devriez monsieur le premier
ministre et fléchir dégâts des lois
toxiques pour l'économie que vous avez
fait adopter telle la loi florange la
loi duflot la loi sur le dialogue social
la suppression des heures
supplémentaires défiscalisées
depuis trois ans françois hollande a
cessé de dire que la courbe du chômage
allait s'inverser et la même affirmé
qu'il ne pourrait être candidat à la
prochaine présidentielle si ce n'était
pas le cas je voudrais à cet égard vous
poser une question monsieur le premier
ministre parce que vous êtes proche du
président de la république et que comme
une majorité de français j'ai beaucoup
de mal à le comprendre
ma question est simple quand ans le
président de la république par inversion
de la courbe du chômage
est ce une baisse de quelques points
quelques mois après l'augmentation
constante
où est-ce l'inversion de la courbe du
chômage à partir du moment où vous avez
pris le pays en main car c'est pour cela
que vous avez été élu et c'est sur cela
que françois hollande s'est
personnellement engagé devant le peuple
monsieur le premier ministre l'heure est
venue d'être honnête avec les français
pouvez-vous répondre à cette question
simple sans envolée lyrique ni
circonvolutions pour vos l'inversion de
la courbe ces deux ou trois mois de
baisse
au moins de chômeurs par rapport à 2012
la parole est à monsieur michel sapin me
des finances et des comptes publics et
il vous plait merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député merci doivent
rajeunir de quelques mois par votre
question mais le sujet nous concerne
tous que ce soit tous les bancs où que
ce soit chacun des ministres de ce
gouvernement
monsieur le député soyons clairs le
chômage a explosé dans les cinq ans
précédents parce qu'ils étaient
largement plus élevé de plus de cinq
cent mille chômeurs de plus qu'au moment
de l'élection de monsieur sarkozy et que
ce chômage n'a pas cessé d'augmenter
y compris au cours des derniers mois et
des dernières années de ce quinquennat
notre objectif il est il s'exprime
simplement
même si chacun devrait être suffisamment
modeste pour savoir que ce n'est pas si
simple à atteindre
il s'explique simplement nous voulons
faire reculer le chômage
faire reculer le chômage c'est simple
comme expression et que fois en
faisons-nous
nous avons d'abord ça a été toute une
partie de notre travail et compris du
mien mis en place avec le soutien de
cette majorité qui a eu raison de le
faire
parfois même avec le soutien plus large
d'une partie de cette assemblée et des
bancs de l'opposition
des mécanismes pour aider tout
particulièrement les jeunes qui étaient
en difficulté qui devait retrouver un
espoir qui devait retrouver une
formation pour leur permettez va leur
permettre d'affronter l'avenir
et maintenant la grande bataille qu'est
la nôtre celle que nous sommes en train
tout juste de gagner mais qu'il faut
conforter c'est celle du retour de la
croissance
le premier trimestre de cette année a
été un premier trimestre positif très
positif
nous souhaitons je l'espère avec votre
soutien ou si c'était avec votre soutien
avec votre souhait avec votre propre
volonté même intérieur vous n'avez pas
besoin de l'exprimer
nous souhaitons avec votre soutien que
cette croissance soit plus forte quand
une croissance forte
une croissance durable c'est la
certitude de faire reculer durablement
le chômage